you have this dream gig it's a dream gig
for just about anybody it's particularly
a dream gig for you because you were
such a car fanatic you were the host of
Top Gear the United Kingdom and people
love the show and you're a huge car nut
and I was I actually went in your
dressing room and we were just before
the show and we both wailed up but the
thing we do it's a thing and we were
talking cars and you were talking about
some of the cars you you've had a chance
to drive and I was wondering to any of
your today of your castmates on friends
with a into cars as well was anyone else
a car not because I didn't think so I
thought you were the only one yeah I
mean I was definitely the most in a car
swimmer a little bit but surprisingly
Courtney is a cardinal Courtney can't
slow cars Courtney Cox loves cars yeah
yes she she would always you know she
and she would get bored with cars very
quickly you know so she always had the
rotating cars she showed up when she'd
say well I'm think about getting this
what do you think you know I gotta go
she talks real fast yeah yeah and so she
showed up one day she had the like a hot
rod Mercedes station wagon and I was
like station wagon
what are you pregnant what's going on
most women tell someone they're buy a
station wagon yeah I got to move a lot
of stuff at my dogs and this snows like
oh okay I got my god
so you know she would always talk to me
whenever it was time to get a new car I
would try to give good advice right
right but you probably like I mean we're
talking again before the show you you
get to you get to drive things now crazy
I mean Ferraris Lamborghinis you get to
drive some fun really fun stuff yeah are
you ever worried you're gonna break one
of those things when you're on the show
yeah yeah
we go through a lot of tires riots is
kind of fun you know it because if it's
your car tires on these like expensive
cars are expensive they're like $900 a
tire in the back or something right
crazy amount like that so but you know
if it's a some trick Mercedes or Porsche
or Ferrari and we have the racetrack for
the day right these kind of keep your
foot in it and it's just a smoke show
until it pops yeah and you kind of go oh
okay let's get on the radio to get a new
tire out here yeah and they come running
out put new tires pretty nice just build
to say let's get a new tired I would
like to host this exact same kind of
show except it's all very under priced
sensible cars you know like I would do a
version of like called mid to low gear
but it's all things like today I'm
taking the neon out the Dodge Neon I'm
gonna take it out on the track and I'm
gonna do 35 miles an hour
good luck I bet your people would like
that show right yeah we do some other
cars and they're not all supercars we
did we just did a film on this for the
new season and the Citroen 2cv you know
that is no I don't
it's like Frances answer to the
Volkswagen bug developed in the early
30s
I'll get farmers into automobiles like
affordable transportation and we did a
big film about that it like was a big
step forward for France and in terms of
the automobile so like it's not all
about super fast cars because that one
doesn't go fast at all you know the the
car that I owned when I got this gig 24
years ago was in 1992 Ford Taurus and I
kept it and if you want talking about
letting parting with that because I got
my wallet you couldn't afford this
sentimental value I want to do it I want
to do a segment with you on top gear
where you and I go in my Ford Taurus my
92 Ford Taurus that's what it's an SH
show that's got the stick shift yeah
that more it was built yeah wolf in
sheep's clothing yeah yeah you know I'm
surprised is 92 is the good 193 yeah no
I knew what I was doing I was no idiot
I got no women with that car all right
you